este martes comenzada la segunda fecha
de esas eliminatorias sudamericanas y la
región se prepara para una sola jornada
en donde se van a disputar todos los
partidos
bolivia argentina habrá en la fecha
ecuador se enfrentará después a uruguay
por su parte venezuela y paraguay se
miden en un duelo de países que no
pudieron ganar en la primera fecha perú
recibe a brasil en la repetición de la
última final de la copa américa y chile
se mide ante colombia santiago para
cerrar la noche aunque el albiceleste
ganó por la mínima en su debut ante el
jugador argentina que donde duda en lo
que se refiere a su juego este martes
tiene un duro enfrentamiento a 3600
metros de altura en la paz esto dijo el
técnico argentino lionel scaloni
principio que creo que ellos de local
van a salir a atacar como ha sido
siempre en la altura
y además su entrenador es un entrenador
que le gusta el fútbol ofensivo así que
seguramente así sea no tendrá nada que
ver el partido de brasil de ellos